[Music]
[Applause]
brian windhorst a very busy man we
always appreciate when he stops by makes
us smarter espn senior nba writer i
think we're all guilty of wishful
reporting there windy and it felt like
that's what it was yesterday like kyrie
to the lakers so that's why i thought
let's separate fact from fiction here
what do you think transpired yesterday
and where's that gonna lead us in say a
week
so this is a leveraged game that kyrie
is playing that's a leverage game that
nets are playing i mean um right now as
you can imagine the nets don't believe
that there's a lot of teams that are
willing to pay kyrie irving uh
35 to 40 million dollars which is his
max salary i think he actually got to 42
million frankly there's not that many
teams that have that kind of gap space
maybe one or two um and you know frankly
even other teams that potentially would
be able to sign him how many people
really want to commit to kyrie irving
after what they've watched the last
couple of years so the nester you know i
think the nets want to keep kyrie but i
don't think they want to give him a
five-year contract for over 200 million
dollars i think they want to give them
something that's much shorter and even
if it is got multiple years on it they
want to have some protection so that
kyrie doesn't
you know do what he's done the last
couple of years on them and i think
that's natural and if you're kyrie
irving i think you're saying i'm in
demand i am an all-star player in my
prime there's no reason why i should
settle for less and teams like the los
angeles lakers and new york knicks
probably want me um and where this gets
complicated as two reasons one you have
kevin durant out there
because if kyrie irving leaves for
nothing which i'll discuss in a minute
about that possibility
um durant's going to be like i'm about
to turn 34 years old i'm in a four-year
contract here and we're in a rebuild now
facing somewhat of a rebuild here i'm
not down for that and then what is
durant's move so really kyrie's sort of
backstop is but what are you going to
tell kevin
even if kevin isn't 100
in love with the partnership that he has
with kyrie he realizes they're better
with him than if he walks for nothing um
the second thing is and i think this is
where the nets have to sort of scratch
their chins
is kyrie irving really willing to walk
away from this 36 million dollar player
option that he has
could he act because the most
the lakers can pay him dan
is about six and a half million bucks
that's what they have okay
and um any wishful thinking about
russell westbrook and two future first
round picks or
taylon horton tucker or whatever
hopeless focus you can come up with to
make it work in the trade machine the
only trade that the nets would be
willing to do for for kyrie irving with
the lakers would be for anthony davis
and the lakers are not trading anthony
davis for kyrie irving and nor should
they so
do you or anybody actually believe that
kyrie would walk away from a 36 million
dollar player option which is sitting
there
to go sign for six million dollars with
the lakers or if he wanted to go to the
knicks he could sign for 10 million
um now this is a guy who left 15 million
dollars roughly on the table last year
because he wouldn't get vaccinated
it is not
i mean i've never seen a player make a
move like this but i can't sit here and
tell you that
it's impossible it's also not impossible
that a team like the knicks could start
trading pieces off
uh to clear salary cap space and maybe
they couldn't get to 40 million but
maybe they could get to
25 million and so the the drop off
wouldn't be as dramatic um but you know
but that's really you know the the
landscape that we've got here
yeah i agree with you with kyrie
that would he do this to kevin durant
and also it is kyrie where i don't know
what money means to him he's the only
player that i could probably say that
where you go lance is kyrie b and kyrie
where he's going to go i'm going to go
play with lebron does lebron want kyrie
i guess that would be another question
so
lebron kyrie relationship is complicated
you're asking a simple question a yes or
no question i can't give you a yes or no
answer i think lebron would play with
kyrie
if all things were equal would would he
rather have kyrie as his point guard
than russell westbrook i think that's a
simple one of course he would would he
want to trade anthony davis for kyrie no
he would not would he love kyrie to come
play with his team for six million
dollars and add him to the team that
they already have yes he would um
so a couple years ago when kyrie was
going to be a free agent um the first
time 2019 after lebron's first year in
la
where the lakers obviously needed more
talent
uh there was a thawing between the two
of them there was a phone call and i
can't remember who called whom but there
was like this
hey
what what we did wasn't so bad right we
were buddies we could be buddies again
and it was pretty transparent that was
because kyrie was going to be a free
agent and lebron needed help
and it didn't work out that way uh
lebron ended up getting anthony davis
and kyrie ended up teaming up with kevin
durant and so i think
could they be friends of convenience yes
i believe they could be friends with
convenience but i i really think
that unless kyrie makes a historic
move and not only that but dan i i don't
want to bore you with salary cap
gymnastics because i know that lakers
fans may be yelling about sign and trade
sign and trade
the lakers functionally long story short
the lakers functionally can't do a sign
in trade the only way the lakers could
really
realistically trade for kyrie would be
if he opted into his contract for next
year and then forced that's to trade him
and if he opted into his contract
the nets would then have them at 36
million and say okay well if you don't
want to sign an extension with us we'll
just play out
the 36 million so i i think it's a i
think the knicks i could draw you a
white board where i could explain how
the knicks could make it happen i think
that's something we could talk about i
think the lakers is i can't close the
door on it but i think it's a real long
shot but it feels like and i'll go back
to what i said initially with wishful
reporting as soon as somebody could be
available the knicks and lakers are
always mentioned
because you're going to get clicks
whether it's it could actually happen
like the clippers would probably have a
better chance of getting kyrie than the
lakers would is that fair
yeah i think um so the big question
there is tyron liu
who
was a huge supporter of it's so funny
and all these connections come back
around again because you're like well
wait maybe durant could play with
westbrook again and lebron could play
with kyrie again
tai lu
tai and kyrie ended on horrible terms
i would even argue that ty and kyrie
ended on worse terms than
than lebron and kyrie when you get right
down some of the stuff that was said
um but i also know that ty lue
would get past it because he's uh
but you know in terms of you forget that
ben simmons plays for the nets
and this is the thing the leverage that
kyrie has as i said is that durant would
want him also
in theory
and jeez we all we only have to talk
about theory i mean
ben simmons has become a theoretical
player quite frankly
in theory ben simmons
playing alongside kyrie and durant with
joe harris who was a very important role
player for them who was out of last
season in theory that core team plus
they got a couple of
first-round picks
in that deal with with philly that they
could now flip for potential role
players and andre drummond is a funk is
a is a helpful player
uh as a backup like there's no reason
why the nets as structured
couldn't really be a serious contender
if they're healthy and functioning well
together it's a giant if
so
yeah i i could create you a trade from
the clippers where they traded off three
role players and having those three role
players
uh you know norm powell and
reggie jackson and brandon boston like i
could i would say to you that having
those three players would be better than
having zero for kyrie irving but again
the only way that functionally works dan
is if kyrie opts into his contract
if he opts out and goes into a sign-in
trade situation it makes it almost
impossible for the clippers to trade for
him because of this hard cap rule you
just have to trust me
so again once the nets once he picks up
the option with the nets what's the
net's motivation to trade him so it's
really a study in leverage and i my
belief is
over the next eight days we're going to
talk about this a lot but the kyrie
irving is probably going to end up being
a net i can't say for sure
but that's still my projection yeah i
agree with you we're talking to brian
windhorst the espn senior nba writer i
was wondering about this opening up the
show if you're kevin durant you just saw
steph curry win another title and i
don't know how important legacy is to
kevin durant where he looks at this and
wants to be considered a better player
than steph curry i got to win another
championship here like the importance
the clock is ticking when you turn 34
you know that window of opportunity
shrinking rapidly
help me understand kevin durant if you
can that how important is
where he ends where he leaves the game
so let me tell you i hope chauncey
billups doesn't have a problem with me
sharing this conversation it's not like
four or five years old
chauncey phillips educated me on
something a few years ago so chauncey
was up for the president job of the
cleveland cavaliers
after david griffin left uh two years
after they won the title and i was
talking to chauncey about he was my
co-worker espn i said chauncey i think
lebron is going to leave i think
lebron's going to walk if you go to
cleveland he was deciding on the job
now we said i think he's gonna walk and
you're gonna have to rebuild that from
scratch uh i just you know i that might
feel like he's gonna leave and chauncey
said that's okay i said what do you mean
that's okay if lebron walks the cavs are
gonna be a nightmare he goes no
if lebron walks you get a chance to
build a champion from scratch and that's
what we all want to do
all right what are you talking about and
chauncey explained to me
that
he was a champion he you know he didn't
need to prove anything in his life that
there was such a rewarding
feeling of creating a team on your own
and building it up that is why
the title this year for golden state
that is why they celebrated it and it
felt different to them than the two
durant titles because
not all championships are created equal
and that
i'm a big believer in not denigrating or
putting an asterisk on any championship
but i can only tell you what players ex
describe to me
there's a more tangibility
to what the warriors just did versus the
previous two championships and so what
durant wants is that tangibility and so
that's what he was looking for when he
came to brooklyn
it he obviously knew if he stayed in
golden state he could probably win more
he wanted something that he could wrap
both arms around and that's why i say
like i've told this to the people with
the bucks organization
the bucks winning that title last year
is one of the highest value titles that
we've seen because they truly built it
from scratch
with guys that they put together and
they they want it in a small market and
and the way they want it was so
impressive i i have told
people from the box you can go another
20 30 years and even if you win more it
will never feel as great as that title
did that is what durant is going for
that is that where me and kyrie irving
got together and we did it together and
he's still holding on to that he still
wants it and i'm here to tell you
while i'm not impressed with what the
nets have done to build this team
it's still that ring is still there for
them to grab and i think kyrie realizes
it and durant realizes it and that is
why they are probably loath to let it go
even though it's been rusty and even
though it's been difficult
thanks for spending time i know you're
busy this morning uh always appreciate
it brian thank you thanks dan have a
good day that's brian windhorst espn
senior nba writer